[Musique]
tu fais quelque chose ce soir est ce que
tu veux tu éclaté avec la courte mais au
moins je suis un peu surpris mais
auxquelles accèdent à minuit au sous-sol
niveau c'est alors on fait quoi
je voudrais que tu rythme car tu me
laisses une minute et ensuite tu me
rappelles
ok là c'est le moment que tu me dis que
c'est une blague
qu'est ce qui nous arrive après la mort
la seule façon de le savoir c'est de
vérifier par nous-mêmes
[Applaudissements]
on pourrait rédiger une étude sur cette
expérience tu avais une lumière blanche
ça ressemblait plus à de l'énergie pure
et elle joue du piano maintenant on
dirait que son cerveau a été reprogrammé
je veux être le prochain
chargée à 200 c'est un bon jour pour
mourir
on dégage
[Musique]
je vais guérir tous ceux qui pensent
autrement aujourd'hui un réveil
spirituel trois minutes
jimmy on a fait tout qu'est ce que tu
veux on a l'esprit de compétition je
suis la prochaine 100 minutes 7 minutes
personne n'est jamais sûr vu que ça
[Musique]
c'était si bien que ça et rien quitte à
perturber
il se passe des choses étranges
je crois que je deviens folle peut-être
qu'on a ouvert une porte
[Musique]
quelque chose nous veut du mal
quelque chose que j'ai fait mon domaine
[Applaudissements]
des fibres il interpelle repart pas il
faut arrêter immédiatement cette
expérience pour dégager
toi je te prie et j'aurais dû vous dire
que je faisais pas ça pour les avancées
de la science on dégage
minutes je pensais pas que les effets
secondaires allait apparaître les
traquer
on a garé
c'est tellement fou
[Musique]